some days the line I walk turns out to
be straight other days the line tends to
deviate I've got no criteria for sex or
race I just want to hear your voice I
just want to see your face guess there's
something wrong with me guess I don't
fit in no one wants to touch it no one
knows where to begin
I just want more than one membership to
more than one club because I owe my life
to the people that I love so those
aren't my words those are Ani DiFranco
'he's from the song in or out and they
were the opening lyrics to introduce my
intro LGBT studies class in the fall
which which opened up all sorts of
questions for the remainder of the
semester so who's demanding that on
these desires fit into one category or
what does it mean to even have a desire
without criteria for sex or race is this
a kind of amp them for bisexuality is it
this aspiration for a world without
categories is that even advisable or
possible so these are the kinds of
things that started off the class and
got students pretty excited and so from
there we so so so the class is a it's
designed for sophomore majors in women's
gender and sexuality studies and so my
thought was to introduce them to a host
of important thinkers and ideas in the
study of sex and gender
you know what's the historical
relationship between this odd thing
called gender and this the furry shifty
thing called sexuality and so we used
all of these various Scott forms of
scholarship to gain some traction on
that question we also long do I looked
at worked on aids and AIDS activism and
the relationship between sexuality and
race and class politics in the US and
abroad so we also so so from there we
explore we explored gender and sexuality
in a transnational context so how far do
LGBT travel what are other ways gender
and sexuality are organized across the
globe or even organized here in the US
we screened Glee and The Birdcage and
Paris is burning by Yale's
Jenny Livingston we talked a lot about
representation even more about drag and
students love talking about drag and
what drag offers for our understandings
of gender and sexual forms how drag is
inflected by by by other forms of social
axes of difference towards the end of
the class we also looked at important
u.s. case law around sodomy and same-sex
marriage and implication and transgender
employment discrimination and at the end
of the in orders in our last class for
an evening section we had a transgender
law student come talk with us about
various pressing issues around
transgender folks in the law and so the
the class dynamic it were there were
mostly women about 15 students some
queer women mmm several students of
color one lone straight white guy I seem
to always have one lone straight white
guy in all my classes and I do my best
to make sure he doesn't think he's like
the bad guy and so so there was lots of
different politics floating in the class
at some point it occurred to me that
half the class sort of I had this what i
called gay affirmative mode and the
other half had this queer skeptical mode
so when we watched Glee or The Birdcage
you know the half of the class who were
sort of just coming out or just thinking
about their sexuality all
representational forms were like yay gay
and they saw their struggle in in the
forum and that was great and exciting
and the other half you know their
approach was sort of Glee is transphobic
or femme phobic or homophobic and so
both interpretations were a little bit
too hasty so over the course of the
class we were able to get to a better
more complicated elsewhere which was
great I'll say a word about the final
projects because I thought they were
particularly delightful and rewarding to
to read and to watch students have the
option of doing either a research paper
or a creative project the research paper
asked them to pick four topics that we
didn't cover adequately enough
in our syllabus and my hope there was to
kind of preempt the well you forgot
about you know this thing like lizards
and sexuality and so if they want to
explore lizards in sexuality they could
but it actually turned out to be great
so we got all sorts of research papers
on Native American sexualities and and
gay life in urban China and then the
creative projects were you know you
could do a poem or art or photography or
any kind of artistic performance that in
some way integrated the ideas and
materials that circulated in our course
and and those were just also outstanding
we had a series of black and white
photographs from a student on on feet
and armpits and all sorts of like non
gender II parts of the body to think
about you know what do we what does
gender look like when we're when we stop
looking at the Gendry parts and the
focus on sensuality and not sexuality
one student reported to be from the homo
Taliban this you know kind of
fictionalized queer terrorist group
demanding freedom from hetero
respectability and gay normativity so
feistiness was like a big you know
there's a lot of feistiness in the class
that was both cultivated and then
checked personally I work on the
regulation of sexuality mostly in the
u.s. context and at the intersections of
normative political theory public law
and feminist and queer studies so I'm
working on two book projects right now
one is called sex and harm in the age of
consent and it looks at the figures of
the child and the sex offender in US law
and media culture and also the
importance of consent in our organizing
and in our understandings of sexual harm
and freedom and the second book the
awesome title to be discovered in the
future is on sex work in in Louisiana
and the way some forms of sex work
become sex offense and in how that's
transpired into the my courses here I
teach a class on on consent called
theories and politics of sexual consent
which canvas is important political
theory and feminist theory on consent
and then
and looked at different cases so
intergeneration ality and career
sexualities and HIV transmission and
then we have particularly provocative
sessions on zoophilia which it has
become a favorite session for students
because you've learned all sorts of
things about consent that you wouldn't
expect to learn and then I also taught a
class called sexuality and social
justice this last semester which was
which was awesome
where where we just we looked at really
you know the central work in Anglican
American theory on social justice and
asked well how would sexuality alter
alter this story and what does what does
it mean to think about sexual justice
against the game against the background
of the dominant political philosophy is
on justice one of the thinkers we
encounter in inter LGBT studies is
Judith Butler we won't have a seminar
right now on Judith Butler and feminist
theory but as many of you know maybe
some of you don't know an important
thought for her is gender as a series of
practices practices that both people
perform and are performed on people and
as a particularly awesome gift from a
student of mine in that class I received
this bumper sticker